so I've been watching this for about 10
minutes now I've got no idea what
they're banging on about it's a pretty
sweet green one to be fair it's got pool
tables it's got massage chair I think
we're in West Virginia yeah exactly
Maryland it's like I said mate the only
thing I know about Maryland is that when
I was at school in my shitty
comprehensive in South London that's
where the cookies came from so we are on
our way to Washington to meet with the
venerable Dr Sebastian Gorka interview
him be interviewed by him but yesterday
we had dinner with the wonderful top
level bigot that is Dougie Murray that
was great what we're doing right now
mate is we're gonna have some sandwiches
well I'm gonna have some sandwiches and
Constantine's gonna drive this has been
an incredible first leg of the trip
we've had Korean food we had steak
yesterday and we have we've had all
different tops we've had great breakfast
great lunch we went to Russian daughters
had Bagels free bagels for about 60
dollars mate and when I said to the
fella behind the counter I went what
three bagels and bagels for 60 bucks he
just looked at me when these are the
best beagle you're ever gonna have sir
yeah and that the moral of that story is
never argue with the Jew yeah it's about
money yeah you know what he was a sexy
Jew he looked a bit why do you sound
surprised mine won't it's plenty of sexy
Jews look at me yeah look I'm gonna be
honest your people aren't the best
looking but this guy was sort of like a
sexy Burt Reynolds had had the hair and
he just looked at me and when he said
that I thought I'd [ __ ] you so there we
go 60 dollars for bagels this city has
absolutely spunked us financially it's a
great City but send us money send us
money send us money so Francis can eat
more he's eating a lot to be fair and
Dougie Murray doesn't take it easy on
the cocktails oh mate how many did he
have about 50 and then when the bill
came it was like you've got this haven't
you yeah thanks Dougie yeah I mean we
did plan to to treat him yeah listen had
a bit of courtesy mate you know I like
about Dougie Wright is that he just went
for the gayest cocktail on the menu and
then just it wasn't even on the menu it
wasn't no he had them made up specially
didn't he he had him he had a specially
extra gay cocktail man made just for him
so he smashed him back and basically
we've got no money that's what's
happened next stop Washington
Seb if you're watching mate lend us a
20.
oh my three stages Jesus Christ that was
ridiculous I think let's get out of here
that woman that ran past wearing
absolutely nothing yeah I think she
seemed like a great potential although
we obviously don't know if she's a woman
no we don't no she could be of
indeterminate gender but but let's just
say she got our attention or he got it
no Zim Zim got our attention exactly can
I just make it clear I'm sorry that we
do actually do some work while we're
here we're not just here to eat food I
mean I know that's what Francis thinks
but actually that isn't the case I'm
quitting trigonometry I'm starting my
food blog it's gonna be food with
Francis looking forward to seeing you
for the next update said but we really
need some money mate because I'm [ __ ]
skin sandwiches no they're not my best
because I was on the time constraint and
I was also limited by various factors
which are too complicated and too secret
to go into now
but he's Constance eating brown bread a
bit of uh Philadelphia cheese and some
salami is it good yeah yeah so there you
go mate gosh we've got yogurt in there
and I've got other I've got a bit of
Saucy sun in there all right and I made
you a sandwich well I don't say sausage
song it sounds like you stuck your dick
in it yeah Saucy song
that's what I do every Friday night
my car just decided to randomly break in
front of us we could have crashed into
it but no we survived exactly what we
are met with survivors yeah we're not
fiance we've got a massive ass yeah
after all those restaurant meals
Francis you should be a hot bird at the
back man
we're real gangsters as you can see
tonight I am on Tim cast Tim Paul show
should be good it could get feisty
I suspect we have very different views
of the war in Ukraine so if they bring
it up
both barrels will be given and then
we're getting on a little plane
to Bangladesh we're getting on a plane
and flying to the Lone Star State of
Texas oh
Freedom [ __ ] and we're gonna
meet a little somebody
[Music]
we're listening to country music
greatest music in the world America
music
[Music]
so we're here at in Washington just
arrived we're fashionably late and we're
about to do some caucus radio show we're
very excited and uh it's gonna be a lot
of fun tell your face mate my phone's
never excited
president Trump I'm Sebastian bulka this
is America first I do have a sense of
humor a little bit more than Mr G Jeff
do I have a sense of humor I do have a
better sense of it
Eric Eric who's got the better sense of
humor me or Mr G Francy there is Francis
Foster and he is half of the dynamic duo
can't believe they're in studio I'm
going to just Fanboy out here it is the
lads from trigonometry the podcast did
you like seb's approach of bullying
subordinates into claiming he has a
sense of humor yeah
you never make fun of Anton no no never
live made fun of it no he's very true
but you've seen the size of him he's
small but he's ferocious what brings you
to American guys well we wanted to come
over here because no Constantine is
promoting his book but because we're we
love America I love America Constantine
does and America is where things happen
I'll say it live on a three million
listeners plus all the viewers best UK
podcast when Boris Johnson the
conservative leader is doing something
bad we will mock him and when the labor
Leader's doing something bad we will
mock him that's what I think the culture
needs right now people are willing to
step out of the two-party system and
actually make fun a joke about criticize
whatever's going on whoever was doing
nice all right thank you so much we'll
see you later on yeah all right so we're
on the road we have come from New York
to Washington we did Seb Gorka show we
were late but we still did say good
morning sorry Seb but we still did it
and now we had a little bit of food and
seb's house God bless you Seb Parma ham
excellent two brilliant dogs as well and
now we're in the car going uh to get
swatted exactly uh we are going for me
to do Tim cast that would be great uh
never been swatted looking forward to it
uh Francis how would you like a gun in
your face mate well I you know what I'm
not from pooping no exactly I'd like it
if it was a big woman doing it because
they're two you know what I mean two
birds one stone bush that doesn't even
make any sense no but if you say Bosch
at the end it makes it funny yeah
exactly
[Music]
that moment
those rocks in the middle of the river
oh up there yeah
so I've been watching this for about 10
minutes now I've got no idea what
they're [ __ ] banging on about
it seems so insane so where are we oh no
idea mate we're somewhere got no idea
where we [ __ ] up I mean it seems like
they know what they're talking about but
I've got no idea what they're banging on
about what about that kissing fella yeah
I mean Easter dog seems good get a book
the Democrat Party so we're in the Green
Room at Tim cast IRL Constantine is
upstairs doing the show it's a pretty
sweet green one to be fair it's got pool
tables it's got massage chair very lots
of nice Side Foods you've got lots of
sketches over there of people who've
been on former guests over there's a
toilet got a little bar over there so
we'll have to go to toilet for our one
yeah we're gonna need a toilet mate
people have been complaining about it
for a long time I think we're in West
Virginia we're in West Virginia
yeah exactly Maryland it's like I said
mate Maryland so uh the only thing I
know about Maryland is that when I was
at school in my shitty comprehensive in
South London that's where the cookies
came from all right everybody so the
morning after the temple show very good
we had a lot of fun uh Tim unfollowed me
on Twitter after couldn't handle the
banter mingy little slag correct no we
had a great conversation I enjoyed it if
you haven't checked it out yet go watch
it and this morning we are with one of
our biggest fans here in the UK the
venerable Dr Sebastian Gorka and he's
taken us to shoot some guns
yeah mate we're going to shoot some guns
I'm gonna shoot up some [ __ ]
that's how we use the vernacular on the
streets is that what you're wearing your
hat like that yeah exactly man because
that's what you do when you shoot
[ __ ] you wear hands like this
means his own foot
foreign
exactly so we're going to be doing that
I've come fully prepared and by that I
mean I've got sunscreen so it's going to
be good looking forward to it mate and
they're all gonna burn
but we're gonna have fun we're gonna
look like Lobsters by the end of it but
it's going to be great we're going to be
looking at very problematic right-wing
lobsters and I'm just gonna look the
same because I'm already Brown okay we
are in
the biggest gun show in America yes in
Virginia in Virginia so that's where we
are we've been around we've been looking
at all the guns and the problematic
t-shirts of which there are many my
favorite one with silver one they said
my two favorite things in life are
getting pain and getting laid and
apparently birds love it yeah and it
really encouraged you to be quite polite
when you're around that many guns you
know what I mean hey look an armed
Society is a polite Society I have heard
that now when I've been around this many
guns I kind of see why and normal people
right just normal Americans you can come
here get a musket you can get whatever
you want the latest AR-15 amazing
atmosphere and have you ever seen this
much Freedom no we haven't I'll tell you
what the the best bit of Freedom that we
saw is the deactivated I think like
artillery shell or something like
rockets yeah I want that as a
doorstopper by a studio yeah we might
have a bit of trouble taking it back to
you might have a real issue on the
customs
[Music]
we just bought some ammunition and we're
about to hit the range Francis you
excited I'm really excited it's going to
be really really good fun uh and I'll
try not to enter anybody else that will
probably more likely myself yeah I just
look forward to him doing a back
somersault when he plays the magnet yeah
excellent round for an AR-15 a 62 grain
fillet and that's a great price so I'm
going to buy me one of these
[Music]
what size is that this one's a three
eggs and I'm fat and Tall I'll take it
all right
[Music]
and this was for a Glock 26 okay okay oh
or 27. I can do that one the way it sits
for 400. and then the standard color one
color so solid color with nothing on it
none of the accessories I'll do for
either 250 or 300. do you have any for
uh 10 mil or 45 a lot which gun you know
the the Glock 20. the Glock 20 yes this
one right here won't fit your Glock 20
or 21.
[Music]
now about to leave the gun show and
we're going to go and fire some guns but
to me this has been an incredibly
eye-opening experience because when
people who come from the UK like me they
think of America they think of East
Coast they think of West Coast New York
L.A but the reality is there's a whole
different America that we don't get
exposed to and to come somewhere like
this and to experience it and to talk to
people who see the world in a different
way live the world in a different way
and live a different America almost it's
incredible and really eye-opening for me
because in the UK we always get
presented with the
anti-gun argument of which there are
elements that I'm very sympathetic to
but you never get the program argument
so to get it from reasonable people here
who personally believe it who are
obviously good people it's great so
we're going to go and fire some guns and
I can't wait for that all right so we
just had about an hour's training on how
to use Firearms we understand the basics
now which is pointed towards the bad
guys that are over there I'm ready to
kill some paper bite guys I am indeed
he's also ready for dinner I think yeah
I am I'm ready to shoot dinner then
someone can cook and eat and I can eat
it I thought you're supposed to be
cooking Seb how about you look look at
those bad boys check out my toys yeah
these are just some of my this is what
you can do in America uh these are all
semi-auto uh G36 H and K Daniel Defense
Mark 18 this is what our special
operators use then a very customized
AK-47 and then really you know this is
what an M4 is this is what the the US
military uses civilian version and we
have just spent an hour not just
learning the basics but with a command
master sergeant of the seals so it
doesn't get I mean I'm learning stuff
and I thought I knew about guns so
that's what we're doing here we're going
to put it to practice by the way this is
obviously this is from motherland but it
is very heavy even though it's made out
of polymer so all this stuff is polymer
right so this well this is this is all
customized this is polymer this
yes very good yeah but it's very heavy
very very heavy so yeah it's going to be
a lot of fun we're going to start off on
the basics with some pistols and work
our way up to this right so yeah that's
it we'll start with the clocks and we'll
have some fun with the long guns when I
say up lift the sights up find the front
side through the rear
take a slack on the trigger extend your
arms when you feel like you got the shot
break your shot
weapons down here so I want you to pick
it up get both put it plenty straight
down range now see if you relax your
elbows Purl it in drop that thumb keep
your fingers straightened off the
trigger now you have good hand grips
lift the weapon up to your face now
you're concentrating on the chamber
that's it dark spot there should be
nothing chamber roll the weapon up
muscle up you'll see down the hole
that's your magazine well
[Music]
do that again chamber Magwell
okay this time turn your weapon up like
this so you see the bottom magazine well
in front of your target fish in your
pocket get your first magazine
all the way around Francis all the way
around yeah you stick the magazine in
point the muscle at the Target
reach over top
pull one release keeping your finger off
the trigger
hold back and let go pull hard and let
go but let go you got it go take your
fingers sorry yeah fingers off the
trigger let's work your hands here find
your finger on the trigger lean into it
a little bit then go on the trigger
finger on the trigger yeah press break
off one clean shot
and hold the trigger in position
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
guys come on around the table here lay
your weapons down on the table with that
ejection board up
are no longer virgins congratulations
you're all doing this nonsense one shot
done
now listen to this one I want you to
shoot two shots to the chest one to the
head stand by up lean into it
[Music]
stand by your guns up just go ahead
you can go to the head if you want to
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
support it towards the target push the
selector switch down now you're ready to
fire
shoot this the same way you shot the
pistol it fires resets fires resets
now see not that much kick is it oh my
gosh good recoil spray okay just be
famous at the same spot
do you want to walk him through that
yeah real quick all right
let's see what kind of sight
[Music]
step forward with your left foot a
little bit more aim and you're going to
shoot up lean into it a little bit
you're kind of leaning back
oh
excellent
we found this gun
you are now an honorary American it's
the same thing you've got a magazine
you've got a slide that you release and
then you've got a trigger and the same
thing control it let it reset and then
it'll fire now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so you can see it like that okay
magazine push it in all the way
nice
excellent
wow
oh headshot nice hang on don't
crisscross your thumbs like that
excellent
[Music]
clear so here we are with our targets uh
this is the last one this is the Desert
Eagle shots three right next to each
other and two slightly off and this is
the G36
nighttime grouping there from me right
so that's the one you started with so
it's got all the holes in there it's got
all the holes by the way start with this
one start with this one so this is what
we started with no this is the last one
oh is that the last one
the Desert Eagle three headshots and a
couple in the shoulder and this is you
shooting them for suppress them for as
well yeah right now this is a bad look I
have to say there was different targets
this is the one I got so a bunch of
headshots
and some nice chest shots as well Elton
John
one or two misses but apart from that
really nice food yeah coming this is the
one we started with
shows you Center Mass and headshot
beautiful Bosch oh one of the things
that shows you right is look we are like
what we're at the 10 meter Mark yeah
from here to here even Center Mass is
not easy for certainly for another but
even for someone but like this is why
when they're talking about police
shootings and they're like well why
don't you shoot them in the leg because
from this distance you can't even hit a
leg big thank you to Seb and to our
trainer here what a great day did you
enjoy Anton loved it yeah I didn't want
to say his name but well done for outing
him on the internet right
it's not it's not as if there's a lack
of speech I reckon we should hang this
up in the studio just every guest that
comes in just sees this what you're
capable of yeah on brand cool so we've
just finished on the shooting range it
was incredible stuff
um first a Navy SEAL uh Master Sergeant
he's actually it's called a command
sergeant the most senior master sergeant
who was former four years Ram buds which
is the selection for the seals so this
is the real deal yeah he was incredible
it was exhilarating it was actually
terrifying first time you I've ever held
a gun first I'm over before I had a gun
but once you get into it it's so much
fun you can tell this guy has been a
gamer for a while but everybody
accredited themselves very very well
yeah we did indeed even with the Desert
Eagle yeah we even got to shoot so we
got to shoot the Desert Eagle the G36
the a couple of m4s different versions
Glock 19 beans so it was a lot of fun
yeah I had a great time and now we're
heading back a shower dinner party yep
and then off tomorrow sadly but
nonetheless off to see big Joey big Joey
big Joey big Joey who's a gun guy he is
he is a gun awesome
[Music]